A better random tester for these functions would set off making a completely random
and then randomly flipping a random number of bits, so here we're going to make a random number
between 0 and 63 and flip that many bits.
We can make a much better random tester for this particular code by making a random
and then making b a mutated function of a, so it's like that how to do that.
We're going to still make a totally random. All right.
So what we want to do is change our random number generator and here we're going to be
slowing it down by adding a nested loop, so I've changed the number of total random test
to 10,000 instead of 100,000, and so what we want to do is a is still a completely randomly
regenerated 64-bit number and now what we're going to do is initialize b to be a
and now for j in 0 to 63.
For j in 0 to 63, so that is for some random number between 0 and 63, we're going to flip the sense
using Python's XOR operator with one random bit at the input.
And now our new test case is going to be a and a changed version of a
with the idea that that's going to be a better test case.
Let's see if that is indeed the case. So now we've completely covered our code.
There are 27 statements. All of them ran with no partial executions.